GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS AS WE
CLOSE OUT THIS LONG AND
PRODUCTIVE WEEK, WE WANT TO SAY
WELCOME TO FRIDAY. MR.
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? ALAN ALVARADO, GILL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. DALY DODD.
DURAZZO. EGGMAN. GLASER
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO. JONES
LAIRD. LYMAN. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
MIN. NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
BOGUE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO. ROTH
RUBIO. SATO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB.
WIENER WILK. THANK YOU, MR.
SECRETARY. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
ESTEEMED GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY THE SENATE'S
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK ALL TO PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SISTER.
AND LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD, ON THIS MEMORIAL
WEEKEND, WE REMEMBER ALL WHO
HAVE DIED IN THE SERVICE OF OUR
COUNTRY. WHOSE HEARTS AND HOPES
ARE KNOWN TO YOU ALONE. COMFORT
THOSE WHO GRIEVE THE LOSS OF
LOVED ONES. AND LET YOUR HEALING
BE THE HOPE IN THEIR HEARTS.
HEAR OUR PRAYER OF GRATITUDE FOR
THOSE WHO PUT THE WELFARE OF
OTHERS AHEAD OF THEIR OWN, AND
GIVE US HEARTS AS GENEROUS AS
THEIRS. MAY ALL WHO PAY THE
PRICE FOR OUR LIBERTY,
EXPERIENCE, COURAGE, HOPE, AND
STRENGTH THROUGH OUR
COMPASSIONATE SUPPORT AND GENTLE
LOVE. HELP US TO SHARE A WORLD,
TO SHAPE A WORLD WHERE WE WILL
TURN OUR SWORDS INTO PLOWSHARES
FOR A HARVEST OF JUSTICE AND
PEACE. YOU WHO CREATED US, WHO
SUSTAIN US, WHO CALL US TO LIVE
IN PEACE, HEAR OUR PRAYER THIS
DAY. AMEN PLEASE JOIN IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU, SISTER MICHELLE.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
MENGIBAR UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR A SPECIAL
MEMORIAL DAY TRIBUTE. SENATOR
MENGIBAR IS A PROUD MARINE
VETERAN. SHE'S GOING TO HONOR
THOSE CALIFORNIANS WHO WERE
SERVING IN THE MILITARY AND DIED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY SERVING THIS
COUNTRY. MADAM SENATOR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE AS WE ENTER INTO OUR LONG
HOLIDAY THAT WE REALLY REMEMBER
THAT IT'S NOT JUST A TRANSITION
INTO THE SUMMER, BUT A TIME TO
REALLY REFLECT ON THOSE WHO GAVE
THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE FOR OUR
FREEDOMS AND WHO ARE FIGHTING
FOR OUR HOPEFULLY, 100% OF THE
FREEDOMS FOR EVERYBODY. YOU'LL
SEE ON YOUR DESK. I LEFT A
LITTLE CARD OF A PIN, A PIN THAT
I HOPE YOU'LL WEAR THIS WEEKEND
TO ALL THE EVENTS THAT YOU WILL
PARTICIPATE IN FOR US TO NOT
FORGET. AND ADDITIONALLY, THERE
IS A HANDMADE POPPY, CREATED BY
VETERANS AS AN ADDITIONAL
REMINDER OF THOSE WHO JOINED THE
MILITARY. MR. PRESIDENT, WITH
YOUR PERMISSION, I'D LIKE TO
READ THE NAMES OF THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES SINCE JANUARY, AS AN
IMPORTANT REMINDER OF THE PHRASE
SAY THEIR NAME, THEY SAY WE DIE
TWICE. ONE WHEN WE ARE BURIED
AND THE SECOND TIMES SECOND TIME
WHEN OUR NAME IS NO LONGER
MENTIONED. SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE SAY THE NAMES OF THOSE
WHO HAVE LOST. WE HAVE LOST.
MADAM SENATOR, PLEASE PROCEED.
THESE NAMES WERE OBTAINED BY
CORVETTE, AND I WANT TO, DO A
PHÐ NOTE THAT IF WE DID NOT
MENTION A LOVED ONES, I HOPE
CALIFORNIANS WILL LET US KNOW SO
THAT WE CAN HONOR THEM. AND IN A
FUTURE SESSION, SEAMAN LUIS, A
NAVY SEAMAN, LUIS EMILIO MANCERA
, ARMY PRIVATE FIRST CLASS
JUSTIN ALAN HUNT, MARINE CORPS
STAFF SERGEANT JOSEPH PINLAC
PADILLA, MARINE CORPS. PRIVATE
FIRST CLASS CHRISTIAN LEE
TILLETT, FOREMAN, STAFFS. ARMY
STAFF SERGEANT ALDO ALEXANDER
GONZALEZ, PETTY OFFICER, FIRST
CLASS, NAVY. BRANDON MICHAEL
GERBER, ARMY MASTER SERGEANT
COLTON ROGER THICKE, MARINE
CORPS SERGEANT BRANDON MOISES
DIAZ, WHO WAS A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE AND NAVY ENSIGN RICHARD Ó
BELL, MARINE CORPS SERGEANT
PHILLIP JOSEPH EVAN, ARMY
PRIVATE FIRST CLASS CATHERINE
MEDELLIN, ARMY SERGEANT ANTHONY
CHUNG, ARMY PRIVATE SECOND CLASS
JUAN ANTONIO PADILLA, ARMY
SERGEANT AUSTIN JAMES HI. THE
FOLLOWING FIVE NAMES. COLLEAGUES
ARE NOT CALIFORNIANS, BUT RATHER
THE FIVE MARINES THAT PERISHED
ABOUT A MONTH AGO ON OUR LAND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA DURING A
TRAINING EXERCISE, MARINE CORPS
LANCE CORPORAL DONOVAN DAVIS,
MARINE CORPS SERGEANT ALEC
LANDON, MARINE CORPS CAPTAIN
BENJAMIN MOULTON, MARINE CORPS
CAPTAIN JACK CASEY AND MARINE
CORPS CAPTAIN MIGUEL NAVA.
AGAIN, COLLEAGUES, I ASK THAT
YOU SAY THE NAMES OF THOSE THAT
YOU WILL HEAR IN YOUR DISTRICT
SO THAT THEY MAY NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THE SENATE, THOSE IN THE
GALLERY. IF ALL COULD PLEASE
STAND FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GUEVARA, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
FORWARD FOR FORMAL RECOGNITION
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
SENATE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR CABALLERO WITH SOME VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE GALLERY.
WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK TO SENATOR
CABALLERO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD
UNDER ITEM FOUR ON OUR AGENDA
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ, AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN UNDER MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. ITEM
NUMBER ONE, PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29 D, THE FOLLOWING RULES
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM SIX SB 828. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE. WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
TÊ. I REQUEST THAT WE MOVE FILE
ITEM 18, SB 1282 TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. GRANTED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM SENATOR. MEMBERS,
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
FORWARD UNDER CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE'RE FIRST
GOING TO START WITH TWO
DIFFERENT SETS OF THREE
DIFFERENT SETS OF APPOINTMENTS.
AND OUR GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS
FOR THAT. WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO SENATOR GROVE. YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT FILE ITEMS
TWO, THREE AND FOUR. SHE'S
PREPARED TO PRESENT. MADAM
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY.
COLLEAGUES. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JONATHAN
PORAT FOR APPOINTMENT FOR THE
STATE'S CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
OFFICER. MR. PORAT, MOST
PREVIOUSLY. MOST PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
INFORMATION OFFICER WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OFFICE
AND DIGITAL SERVICES. HE WAS
ALSO THE CITY OF SEATTLE'S FIRST
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
ENGAGEMENT MANAGER, AND HE HELD
POSITIONS OF THE US BUSINESS AND
SMALL BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
AGENCY AND ADVOCACY FOR THE US
OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET.
HE WAS APPROVED ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY 8TH ON A50
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATORS ANY DISCUSSION ON
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR? FINAL CALL.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE Ã. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA BORG.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
WILK. AYE MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS ONE MORE
TIME, ALAN ARCHULETA. BLAKE
SPEAR. AYE. OCHOA BORG AYES 37,
NOES ZERO. THE APPOINTMENTS. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE UNDER
GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR
GROVE IS PREPARED. SENATOR
GROVE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. COLLEAGUES, IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
APPOINTMENTS. CAPTAIN LYNN
CARILLO, FOR THE APPOINTMENT TO
THE BOARD OF PILOT
COMMISSIONERS. CHRIS DOWNEY,
CHRIS DOWNEY, SCOTT LILLIBRIDGE
AND LUCIANO PROFETA. ESTÁ. SORRY
FOR THE COMMISSION OF DISABILITY
ACCESS AND TINA MILLER FOR THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE BOARD OF
BARBER AND COSMETOLOGY. THESE
APPOINTMENTS WERE APPROVED ON
THE RULE AT THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON A50 VOTE. MAY EIGHTH. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IF THERE'S DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HEARING. SEEING NONE. MR.
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BORG PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE. MR. SECRETARY, CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE? ALAN ARCHULETA? DURAZO.
AYE. LIMON AYE. OCHOA AYES 37,
NOES ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. WE HAVE ONE FINAL
ITEM ON OUR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. SENATOR GROVE IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR ELLEN CHEN FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE WESTERN
INTERSTATE COMMISSION ON HIGHER
EDUCATION. SHE IS THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY, STANISLAUS, HAVING
SPENT 37 YEARS AS A TEACHER AND
ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE CSU
SYSTEM, SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY 8TH ON
A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM
SENATOR. SENATORS, WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IF THERE IS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR HEARING, SEEING NONE.
MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYES
38. NO. ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST TAKE UP FILE ITEM 21, FILE
ITEM 21, SB 1031, THAT SENATOR
WIENER. MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1031 BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO TRANSPORTATION. GOOD MORNING,
SENATOR WIENER. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1031, THE CONNECT
BAY AREA ACT. THIS IS A JOINT
EFFORT WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD, WORKING TOGETHER ON
THIS. AND THE BILL AUTHORIZES
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION OR AN INITIATIVE
PETITION TO PROPOSE A REVENUE
MEASURE TO FUND, IMPROVE AND
MODERNIZE BAY AREA PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS, AS WELL
AS ROADS AND INVESTING IN A
RANGE OF BALANCED TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITIES, I WANT TO START IN
ADDITION TO THANKING MY PARTNER
IN THIS FOR THE SENATOR FROM
HAYWARD, I WANT TO REALLY THANK,
MY THE CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE REVENUE AND TAX
COMMITTEE, THE SENATORS FROM SAN
JOSE AND ORINDA, FOR WORKING
VERY, VERY INTENSIVELY WITH US
ON THIS BILL. BROAD STAKEHOLDER
WORK, AND I JUST AM VERY, VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THEIR STRONG
ENGAGEMENT, COLLEAGUES,
ADDITIONAL REVENUE IS CRITICAL
TO KEEP PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
RUNNING AND VIBRANT AND
STRENGTHEN IT AND MODERNIZE IT
IN THE BAY AREA, MANY OF OUR
HIGHEST RIDERSHIP TRANSIT
SYSTEMS WERE STRUCTURALLY
UNDERFUNDED AND OVERLY FARE
RELIANT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, AND
IT'S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE THIS IS
AN UNSUSTAINABLE MODEL, AS
RIDERSHIP CONTINUES TO RECOVER
AND TRANSIT AGENCIES FACE MAJOR
SHORTFALLS THROUGH HARD WORK IN
THE STATE BUDGET. LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN SECURING BRIDGE
FUNDING TO PREVENT OPERATING
SHORTFALLS THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
2026. HAD WE NOT OBTAIN THAT
MONEY IN THE STATE BUDGET LAST
YEAR, RIGHT NOW, TODAY, WE WOULD
BE SEEING MASSIVE SERVICE CUTS,
AT VARIOUS OF OUR LARGEST PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS IN THE
BAY AREA BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE DID IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR THAT WAS
DELAYED AND THAT THOSE SERVICE
CUTS UNTIL 2026. NOW WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EMPOWER THE BAY
AREA TO ENGAGE IN SELF-HELP BY
GOING TO THE BALLOT, TO PROVIDE
LONG TERM FUNDING SOLUTIONS FOR
OUR TRANSIT SYSTEMS, SB 1031
DOES NOT ONLY ALLOW FOR A
REVENUE MEASURE, IT ALSO
ADVANCES STRONGER REGIONAL
NETWORK MANAGEMENT, MANAGEMENT
REFORMS, BETTER INTEGRATION OF
THE SYSTEMS, A TRANSPORTATION
DEMAND MANAGEMENT PROVISION. AND
AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUE, I'M SURE, AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF CONSOLIDATION.
THÀNH, COLLEAGUES, THIS IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR
BAY AREA PUBLIC TRANSIT SYSTEMS,
I ALSO JUST WANT TO STRESS THAT
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS, AS
ANYONE WHO'S ENGAGED IN THESE
KIND OF REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING WORK KNOWS, IT WILL TAKE
A LOT OF CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOT
OF STAKEHOLDER WORK, I WANT TO
JUST PUBLICLY EXPRESS THE
COMMITMENT THAT I'VE GIVEN TO
MANY TO ALL OF OUR REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS, OUR COUNTIES, OUR
OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS, ENVIRONMENTAL AND
TRANSIT ADVOCATES, LABOR,
BUSINESS COMMUNITY, MY
COLLEAGUES IN BOTH HOUSES IN THE
BAY AREA, DELEGATION, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK INTENSIVELY. I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE STILL A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO LIKE PARTS OF THE
BILL, WHO DON'T LIKE PARTS OF
THE BILL, WHO WANT TO SEE
CHANGES, AND YOU HAVE MY
CONTINUED COMMITMENT THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
THIS TO TRY TO GET TO A GOOD
LANDING SPOT ON THIS BILL THAT
WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SENATOR
WAHAB. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. I RISE TO CO-PRESENT
SB 1031, THE CONNECT BAY AREA
ACT. PUBLIC TRANSIT ACROSS THE
BAY AREA IS AT A CRITICAL
JUNCTURE. A NUMBER OF AGENCIES
ARE DEALING WITH LOOMING FISCAL
CLIFFS. WE KNOW IF WE CANNOT
FIND FUNDING TO CLOSE THESE
OPERATIONAL GAPS, A NUMBER OF
AGENCIES AND RIDERS WILL SUFFER
AS WELL AS THE WORKFORCE THAT
OPERATE. FRANKLY, OUR REGION
CANNOT AFFORD THAT. WE CANNOT
AFFORD THE INFLUX OF VEHICLES ON
OUR ROADS, AND MANY OF THOSE WHO
RELY ON PUBLIC TRANSIT CANNOT
EVEN AFFORD A VEHICLE. THE BAY
AREA NEEDS PUBLIC TRANSIT, NOT
JUST TO SURVIVE, BUT TO THRIVE.
THAT'S WHY AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
27 AGENCIES ACROSS THE NINE BAY
AREA COUNTIES IS SO IMPORTANT.
MY VISION IS NOT JUST TO AIM FOR
REPAIRS, BUT FOR A SYSTEM THAT
CONNECTS US DEEPER IN THE BAY
AND ONE DAY IN THE FUTURE ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, SB 1031 IS
SETTING THE STAGE FOR THAT
TRANSFORMATION. THE INTENT OF
THE ASSESSMENT IS TO ONE IMPROVE
SPEED, AFFORDABILITY, SAFETY AND
CLEANLINESS, BUT ALSO PROMOTE
CLIMATE GOALS, INCORPORATE
TECHNOLOGY, IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY, IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY
IDENTIFYING ALL THE AGENCIES AND
THEIR GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
FINANCING MECHANISMS, LABOR
AGREEMENTS, AND MOUS AND VEHICLE
FLEETS, AND ASSESSING
CONSOLIDATION AND ENHANCE
COORDINATION AND THEIR IMPACTS.
WE WILL NOT ONLY CREATE GREATER
FISCAL EFFICIENCIES, BUT IMPROVE
EXISTING SYSTEMS TO INCREASE
RIDERSHIP, SUSTAINABLE K¾T THE
OVERALL QUALITY OF BAY AREA
PUBLIC TRANSIT, AND THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR TRANSIT SYSTEMS. THE BAY
AREA DESERVES A WORLD CLASS
TRANSIT SYSTEM, AND WE NEED AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF ALL
THE AGENCY AGENCIES TO HELP US
GET THERE. WITH SB 1031, WE'RE
NOT JUST DREAMING, WE'RE DOING.
WE'RE BUILDING A LEGACY OF
TRANSIT THAT WILL CARRY THE BAY
AREA FORWARD. I DO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
AS WELL AS A LOT OF THE BAY AREA
MEMBERS THAT HAVE SAT ON THIS
WORKING GROUP FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS, AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN THE CONVERSATION,
AGAIN, AS THE SENATOR STATED,
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS. WE
ARE LOOKING FOR ALL INPUT, BUT
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR TRANSIT AGENCIES KEEP
SERVING THE PUBLIC IN AN
EFFICIENT AND BETTER WAY, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MEMBERS. WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
MICS UP, SO LET'S GO THROUGH
THAT ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR CORTESE NEXT, THEN
SENATOR EGGMAN, SENATOR GLAZER
AND THEN SENATOR BECKER. SENATOR
CORTESE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1031, AND IT PAINS ME
GREATLY TO HAVE TO DO THIS BOTH
FIGURATIVELY AND LITERALLY,
LITERALLY, BECAUSE I, ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CONTRA COSTA,
SPENT HOURS UPON HOURS, LEADING
AN INFORMAL WORKING GROUP, THANK
YOU TO THE AGAIN TO MY COLLEAGUE
FOR TAKING THE CHAIR ROLE. WE
ATTEMPTED TO HELP SHAPE THIS
BILL IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY. NO
SUCH LUCK. AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE ANALYSIS, THE BILL STILL
CARRIES WITH IT OPPOSITION FROM
NUMEROUS ENTITIES WITHIN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA REGION,
INCLUDING MY OWN CITY, SAN JOSE,
AND THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE,
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST CITY IN
THE BAY AREA. THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT I LEAD
WORKED VERY, VERY HARD TO BRING
SENSIBLE AMENDMENTS FORWARD IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND A COLLABORATIVE
WAY. BUT DESPITE THE MANY
CONCERNS OUTSTANDING IN THE BILL
, THE MOST IMPORTANT OF THOSE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS DIRECT
RETURN TO SOURCE OF A PERCENTAGE
OF SALES TAX REVENUE WAS
REJECTED. FLAT OUT THAT DIRECT
RETURN TO SOURCE FLAT OUT
REJECTED. YOU COULD READ THE
BILL. ALL MONEY IN THIS BILL
GOES TO THE MPO FOR THE BAY AREA
REGION, WHICH IS A METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION. I THINK
MOST OF YOU HAVE ONE OF THOSE.
THEY'RE A PLANNING ENTITY. THEY
HAVE NEVER RUN TRANSIT OR
TRANSPORTATION OPERATIONS, EVER
IN THEIR HISTORY. THAT'S WHERE
THE MONEY GOES FOR POTENTIAL
REDISTRIBUTION. DEPENDING ON HOW
WELL THEY THINK PEOPLE HAVE
BEHAVED. BUT WE TRIED, THAT
MISSED OPPORTUNITY, COMBINED
WITH SUBSEQUENT AMENDMENTS
OUTSIDE OF MY COMMITTEE, CREATED
A BILL THAT THREATENS TO
LITERALLY BREAK UP THE NINE
COUNTY BAY AREA REGION INTO TWO
SEPARATE REGIONS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, WITH ITS GDP THAT LEADS
A MAJORITY OF COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD, IS TO PREPARE TO TAKE 30%
SALES TAX THAT IT CONTRIBUTES TO
THE REGION AND GO ELSEWHERE,
EITHER FORMING ITS OWN MPO OR
JOINING ONE SOUTH OF IT.
TRANSPORTATION, OF COURSE, IS
THE LIFEBLOOD TO THE THIRD
LARGEST CITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS PEOPLE.
FIGURATIVELY, IT PAINS ME THAT,
GIVEN MY ADMIRATION AND RESPECT
FOR THE JOINT AUTHORS OF THE
BILL, BUT WE'VE SEEN THIS
BEFORE. DESPITE BEST EFFORTS,
SOME COMBINATION OF COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES. AND WE END UP
HERE. WE END UP WITH UNRESOLVED
OPPOSITION. AND IN THIS CASE,
I'D SAY THE UNRESOLVED
OPPOSITION REQUIRES US TO START
OVER FOR. I BELIEVE MY CITY AND
MY COUNTY AND THE TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, WHICH, BY THE WAY, IN
OUR COUNTY IS WALL TO WALL. WE
HAVE ONE OPERATOR. THE REST OF
THE BAY AREA HAS 29 OTHER
OPERATORS, NINE COUNTY REGION.
WE HAVE ONE OPERATOR. THE REST
OF THE BAY AREA HAS NEARLY 30,
BUT I BELIEVE OURS AND ALL THE
PEOPLE I'VE MENTIONED WHO ARE
ELECTED AND REPRESENT POLICY
INTERESTS IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WOULD BE HAPPY TO NEGOTIATE OUT
A BETTER BILL IF THIS ONE WAS
OFF THE TABLE. BUT WITH THIS ONE
ON THE TABLE, THAT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN. THIS IS LITERALLY AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, WHICH HAS PASSED
SALES TAXES IN SELF-HELP OVER
THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN ELECTED
TO OFFICE THAT NOW AMOUNT TO
OVER $800 MILLION A YEAR
COMBINED TO SUPPORT ITS OWN
SYSTEMS, BECAUSE THERE WAS NEVER
HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THERE WAS NEVER HELP
FROM THE REGIONAL GOVERNMENT. WE
PIONEERED IN THE BAY AREA THE
NOTION OF PROMOTING YOUR OWN
SALES TAX AND GOING OUT THE HARD
WAY ON A TWO THIRDS VOTE TO DO
THINGS LIKE THE BART EXTENSION
INTO SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND MANY
OTHER THINGS. THOSE MEASURES,
THERE ARE FOUR OF THEM. THREE OF
THEM ARE COMING UP FOR RENEWAL
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. AS
THIS MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY
WOULD IMPOSE A HALF CENT SALES
TAX AT A REGIONAL LEVEL ON OUR
COUNTY. BUT IT GETS WORSE. IT'S
NOT JUST A DISRUPTION OR
DISPLACEMENT OF POTENTIAL SALES
TAX DEPLOYMENT IN OUR OWN
COUNTY. THE WAY THE MEASURE IS
WRITTEN, IT SAYS THAT A MAJORITY
OF THE COUNTIES BY POPULATION IN
THE NINE COUNTY BAY AREA CAN AND
WILL DECIDE THE EXPENDITURE PLAN
FOR ALL OF THE SALES TAX MONEY.
THAT'S BROUGHT IN A HALF CENT
SALES TAX IS ABOUT $1 BILLION A
YEAR, THE AUTHORS HAVE INDICATED
, AMBITIOUSLY, THAT THEY'D LIKE
TO SEE THIS MEASURE RAISE A
BILLION AND A HALF A YEAR OVER
30 YEARS, SO 45, UP TO $45
BILLION OVER THE NEXT 30 YEARS
WOULD GO TO AN ORGANIZATION, AN
MPO, AND BE REDISTRIBUTED AT
THEIR DISCRETION, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT OTHER MEASURES IT DISPLACES
IN THE FUTURE AND REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THEY DECIDE THAT MONEY
SHOULD GO TO SUBJECT TO BUCKETS
OF THAT THEY HAVE SET UP. BY
DEFINITION, THAT'S WHY I CALL IT
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. CAN'T PUT ITS OWN
SALES TAXES ON THE BALLOT, AND
WORSE YET, HAVE TO PLEAD AND BEG
TO GET MONEY FROM THE MTC, THE
PLANNING ORGANIZATION THAT
THAT'S NOT A GOOD POSITION TO BE
IN, TO SAY THE LEAST. THAT'S
WHY. AND I'M JUST PUTTING THIS
ON THE RECORD, BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO THE PUBLIC OR
ANYONE ELSE TO ACT LIKE THIS IS
JUST MY THOUGHT OR MY IDEA.
THAT'S WHY FOLKS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ARE LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE REMEDIES AND LEGAL
REMEDIES AS WELL. AS I MENTIONED
, LIKE PULLING THE COUNTY OUT.
SO IT'S NOT PUT AT THAT
DISADVANTAGED PLACE. MAKE NO
MISTAKE, THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE
COUNTY, SUPERVISORS AND OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE ROLLING
OUT THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST THE
MEASURE. EVEN THOUGH WE HAVEN'T
GOT INTO THE ASSEMBLY YET
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR THAT WHEN IT
GOES ON THE BALLOT, PEOPLE NEED
TO BE ORGANIZED AND READY. THAT
INCLUDES TAKING ON POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS AND STARTING THE
EARNED MEDIA CAMPAIGN. YOU WILL
SEE THAT IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS. I
KNOW MANY OF YOU FEEL THAT THIS
IS NOT YOUR FIGHT. IT'S NOT YOUR
REGION. BUT GOOD GOVERNMENT IS
ALWAYS OUR FIGHT AND AS WE ALL
KNOW, IF WE SUPPORT LEGISLATION
IN ONE AREA THAT DISADVANTAGED A
COMMUNITY, THEY'RE PROBABLY
COMING FOR YOU NEXT NÓ BAY AREA
COUNTY IS SAFE OR PROPERLY
PROTECTED IN THIS BILL, NOT JUST
MINE. IT'S A DANGEROUS BILL AS
IN PRINT. LET ME TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY THE SPONSOR
IS THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION, THE
ENTITY THAT GETS THE MONEY 1
BILLION TO 1 BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS A YEAR OVER THE NEXT 30
YEARS. I USED TO BE A PROUD
MEMBER AND FORMER CHAIR OF THAT
ORGANIZATION UNTIL JUST
RECENTLY. IF YOU COME INTO MY
OFFICE, YOU'LL SEE A PLAQUE THAT
I WAS GIVEN WITH SOME OF THE
MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENTS DURING MY
PERIOD OF MY TENURE THERE. AND
I'M EMBARRASSED NOW AND ASHAMED
TO BE ASSOCIATED BECAUSE OF THIS
POWER GRAB. AND THAT'S WHAT IT
IS. AND MONEY GRAB THAT'S ON THE
TABLE AND HAS BEEN ON THE TABLE
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS, DESPITE
OUR PLEAS TO AMEND THE BILL TO
MAKE IT EQUITABLE AND FAIR. YES
WE HAVE A BIG GDP. WE DO. 60% OF
THE PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTY ARE
STILL EMPLOYED BY SMALL
BUSINESS. THAT GDP IS PROVIDED
BY A POPULATION THAT IS 40%
IMMIGRANTS, AND THEY PRODUCE 45%
OF THAT GDP. THEY'RE GOING TO
NOW UNDER THIS BILL, SEND THEIR
MONEY TO SAN FRANCISCO AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE BAY AREA. WHEN THEY
GO TO THE CASH REGISTER, THEY
PICK UP ANOTHER HALF CENT TAX, A
REGRESSIVE TAX THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE TOLD NOW. AND THROUGHOUT THE
FUTURE CAMPAIGN IS GOING
ELSEWHERE, NOT TO THEIR POOR
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
CONCERN THAT NEED THOSE DOLLARS
INVESTED LOCALLY IN EQUITY AND
IN JOBS AND IN OTHER THINGS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN PROVIDE.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU MORE ABOUT
THE SPONSOR, BECAUSE AS I SAID,
I CHAIRED THE ORGANIZATION AND
I'LL WRAP UP SOON, BUT I WANT TO
CLOSE BY MAKING SURE THIS IS
CLEAR AS WELL. THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS WIDELY
PANNED AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
IF THIS MEASURE GOES TO THE
BALLOT FOR BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF OVERRUN DOLLARS ON THE BAY
BRIDGE. THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION
WHOSE PAST EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WAS CRITICIZED WIDELY BY ALL BAY
AREA NEWSPAPERS FOR TAKING FIRST
CLASS AIRFARE ON JUNKETS AROUND
THE WORLD, TAXPAYER MONEY
TAXPAYER MONEY. THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WE WILL SOON
FIND OUT, AS MORE IS DISCLOSED,
THAT HAS HAD MASSIVE LITIGATION
EXPENSES FOR MISMANAGING TOLLS
AND FAST TRACK THROUGHOUT THE
BAY AREA, AND IS KEPT AT AS
QUIET AS THEY CAN. AND THIS IS
AN ORGANIZATION THAT SAYS WE'RE
SUCH GOOD MANAGERS THAT YOU, THE
LEGISLATURE, SHOULD EMPOWER US
AND GIVE US $45 BILLION A YEAR
OVER THE $45 BILLION OVER THE
NEXT 30 YEARS. SO WE CAN MANAGE
ALL THESE OTHER ENTITIES. THIS
IS AN ENTITY THAT HAS A FAIRLY
NEW BUILDING IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO, SO THAT THEY FEEL
INCOMPETENT TO MANAGE
THEMSELVES. SO THEY BROKER THE
MANAGEMENT OUT TO CORPORATE
INTERESTS TO MANAGE FOR THEM. I
WAS JUST TOLD BY AN EMPLOYEE
WHEN I SAID, I WANT TO DROP BY
AND DO A LITTLE HOMEWORK THE
NEXT TIME IN SAN FRANCISCO. YOU
CAN'T DO THAT DESPITE IT'S A
PUBLIC BUILDING WITHOUT CALLING
CUSHMAN WAKEFIELD, THE PROPERTY
MANAGER, TWO DAYS AHEAD OF TIME
TO COME INTO A PUBLIC BUILDING
AND SIT DOWN AND READ YOUR
MATERIALS. THIS IS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT WE'RE BEING
ASKED TO EMPOWER WITH $45
MILLION OVER THE NEXT 30 YEARS
TO TEACH OTHER PEOPLE HOW TO
MANAGE THEIR ORGANIZATIONS. AND
THIS IS WHAT I SAY. I DON'T KNOW
IF WE CAN STOP THIS FROM GOING
FORWARD. I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
STOP IT FROM GOING FORWARD. IF
IT COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE, I
WILL BE ASKING FOR AN AMENDMENT
FOR AN INSPECTOR GENERAL. NOT
THAT REPORTS TO THE MTC, BUT IS
INDEPENDENT THAT CAN OVERSEE ALL
OF THESE ISSUES. NUMBER ONE, AND
BEFORE WE GET THERE, AS A MEMBER
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE, BEYOND THOSE EXAMPLES
THAT I JUST GAVE, I WILL BE
ASKING FOR AN AUDIT OF THE
ORGANIZATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT WE CAN
ENTRUST THEM WITH THESE KINDS OF
DOLLARS AND INVESTMENTS. I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO PASS THAT
TEST, BUT OF COURSE, AT THE END
OF THE DAY, IT WILL BE UP TO ALL
OF YOU. AND THEN THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE. I WILL SAY, WHEN THAT
AUDIT COMES OUT AND WHEN SOME
MORE INFORMATION COMES OUT IN
TERMS OF BASIC MANAGEMENT
COMPETENCY, MANY, MANY ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE BAY AREA,
INCLUDING MANY WHO VOTED FOR
THIS MEASURE, ARE GOING TO BE
ASKED, WHY DID YOU DO THAT? WHY
WOULD YOU DO THAT? WHY WOULD YOU
ENTRUST AN ORGANIZATION LIKE
THAT WITH A LEGISLATIVE VOTE TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR $45
MILLION OF OUR TAXPAYER MONEY?
HAVEN'T YOU SEEN ENOUGH? THAT'S
WHERE I THINK THIS IS HEADED. I
REALIZE THIS WILL PROBABLY GET
OFF THE FLOOR TODAY. WE HEAR
IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS. I'VE
BEEN LISTENING TO THAT IN HOURS
AND HOURS OF MEETINGS UP TO THIS
POINT. AGAIN, TRYING TO HELP OUT
. I DON'T HAVE ANY CONFIDENCE
THAT PROGRESS IS GOING TO BE
MADE. WHEN THE LAST SET OF
AMENDMENTS CAME IN AND SET US
BACK EVEN FURTHER AWAY FROM
PROGRESS, IT TOLD ME THAT WE
NEED TO ORGANIZE PEOPLE IN MY
AREA OF THE BAY AREA NEED TO
ORGANIZE, AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PUT A STOP TO THIS. IF IT GETS
ON THE BALLOT, WE'LL SEE HOW IT
GOES. I WOULD URGE YOUR NO VOTE
RESPECTFULLY, AND I UNDERSTAND
AGAIN, WE HAVE PEOPLE HERE FROM
EVERY PART OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I APPRECIATE YOU
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY. K¾T.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY
CASE. THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ.
SENATOR EGGMAN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF, MEMBERS, I ALSO
WRITE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
, THOUGH, I HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR, I REPRESENT AN
AREA PEOPLE MAY HAVE HEARD ME
TALKING ABOUT A VALLEY LINK,
TRAIN THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
CONNECTED, I HAVE 150,000 PEOPLE
WHO COMMUTE EVERY SINGLE DAY BY
CAR OVER THE ALTAMONT PASS TO
GET TO THE BAY AREA, TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT TO A TRAIN OVER
THERE, THE TRAIN THAT WE HAVE
PLANNED, VALLEY LINK, WILL
CONNECT FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
RIGHT UP TO THE BART, WHERE YOU
CAN INCREASE RIDERSHIP, WHICH IS
WHAT WHAT BART NEEDS TO DO,
RIGHT? INCREASE RIDERSHIP. WE
HAVE WAYS TO DO IT. WE ASK TO BE
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED. I WAS
TOLD THAT YOU'RE NOT EXCLUDED IF
SAN JOSE IS NOT INCLUDED AND
WORRIES ABOUT IT, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
STOCKTON LATHROP? TRACY AND THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT SO I WON'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY. I
DON'T THINK IT'S EQUITABLE. I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD CONTINUE
PASSING LAWS THAT BENEFIT SAN
FRANCISCO, WHEN THE REST OF US
ARE SUFFERING A LITTLE BIT AND
ASK FOR A LITTLE BIT OF HELP, SO
UNTIL THERE'S SOME, I THINK,
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THIS,
I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR GLAZER, SENATOR BECKER
AND SENATOR DODD. SENATOR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I GUESS THE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
BAY AREA CAN GET AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE A VERY
DIVERSE FAMILY. IT'S A VERY BIG
TENT HERE IN THE BAY AREA WITH A
LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT VIEWS. BUT I WANT TO
JUST SAY A COUPLE A BRIEF
THINGS. NUMBER ONE IS I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND FROM HAYWARD FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO THE BAY AREA TRANSPORTATION,
AND WE ALL KNOW HOW IT AFFECTS
SO MANY THINGS IN IN OUR LIVES,
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY TO
WORK AND THE REST IN BETWEEN.
BUT THERE'S A COUPLE OF POINTS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE. ONE IS,
AND BY THE WAY, IT COMES OUT OF
BEING A PART OF THIS STAKEHOLDER
GROUP THAT PROBABLY HAD A DOZEN
MEETINGS WITH STAKEHOLDERS OVER
THE LAST 30 DAYS. SO I'VE DUG IN
A LITTLE BIT TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT THESE AUTHORS FACE IN
TRYING TO BRING EVERYTHING
TOGETHER AND IT LEADS ME TO TWO
CONCLUSIONS. ONE IS, IS THAT
THEY'VE TAKEN ON A VERY
COMPLICATED ASSIGNMENT, AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM THE
DEBATE TODAY. I THINK THEY NEED
THE TIME AND DESERVE THE TIME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND TRY TO FIND A WAY TO BRING
EVERYONE TOGETHER, WHETHER IT'S
FOR THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON,
THE SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE, AND
SO MANY OTHER STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS. YOU KNOW, THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN QUICKLY. MANY OF YOU ARE
EXPERIENCED IN THE LAW MAKING
PROCESS. AND, YOU KNOW, ON
COMPLICATED ISSUES LIKE THIS,
YOU DO NEED A LONGER LANDING
STRIP. AND THE AUTHORS HAVE
GIVEN ME A VERY IMPORTANT
ASSURANCE. AND THAT IS THAT IF
THIS BILL GETS OUT OF THE SENATE
TODAY AND THEY'RE ABLE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF US AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY, THAT WHEN
IT COMES BACK AND IF IT COMES
BACK TO THE SENATE, THAT HE WILL
ALLOW BOTH MY COMMITTEE AND THE
SENATOR WHO CHAIRS
TRANSPORTATION TO COME BACK AND
LOOK AT THAT PRODUCT AGAIN AND
MAKE SURE IT MEETS OUR TEST. AND
THAT'S A VERY WORTHY COMMITMENT.
AND IT MAKES ME VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THAT WE SHOULD GIVE THEM
THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND THAT'S WHY
I'M VOTING YES. AND URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB 1031 TODAY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR BECKER
AND THEN SENATOR DODD. GOOD
MORNING, SENATOR BECKER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, I APPRECIATE
THE DEBATE. I REPRESENT PART OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY, ALSO, SAN
MATEO COUNTY, AND CERTAINLY MANY
FOLKS WHO DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS MEASURE, CERTAINLY WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE AND I'M SUPPORTIVE,
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR TRANSPORTATION IN THE BAY
AREA. I'M ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF IMPROVING COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION THÀNH AMONG OUR
REGION'S OPERATORS, WHICH IS ONE
OF THE BIG GOALS OF THIS BILL.
WE HAVE 27 OVERLAPPING TRANSIT
AGENCIES. I CARRIED THE SEAMLESS
BAY AREA BILL TWO YEARS AGO THAT
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE, AND
PARTS OF THAT, SOME OF THAT HAS
ALREADY STARTED TO HAPPEN,
ACTUALLY, WHICH IS POSITIVE. AND
SOME OF THAT IS EMBEDDED HERE
NOW IN THIS BILL. AND I THINK
THAT IS VERY POSITIVE, AS WE'VE
AS WE'VE HEARD, THOUGH, OF
COURSE, THERE ARE REAL CONCERNS
AND SOME OF MY LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AND
HAVE VOICED THOSE CONCERNS IN
THEIR LETTERS AND IN THEIR
DISCUSSION. I'M GOING TO FALL
OUT ON THE SIDE OF MY AS MY
SENATE FRIEND FROM ORINDA
MENTION. I DO THINK THIS IS VERY
COMPLICATED AND NØ. OUR ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A LOT OF
OPINIONS ON THIS AS WELL, AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT IS WORTH MOVING
THIS FORWARD AND CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE,
ULTIMATELY, THE BAY AREA IS A
REGION, AND WE DON'T WANT BART
TO FAIL. WE DON'T MEAN TO FAIL.
WE DON'T WANT CALTRAIN TO FAIL.
WE REALLY WANT TO SUPPORT ALL
THE SYSTEMS, IN THE BAY AREA, I
DO HEAR MY COMMENTS FROM MY
FRIEND FROM STOCKTON.
PERSONALLY, I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT IS WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF CAR COMMUTES
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
INCREASE THAT CONNECTIVITY OUT
THERE, I THINK IS ALSO CRUCIAL,
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. I THINK THERE'S
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF THE
COORDINATION, WHICH IS CRITICAL.
THERE'S FUNDING ELEMENTS THAT
CLEARLY HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE. BUT I HOPE THAT WE CAN
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND I WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS, GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AMONGST THE HAMMERING, WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
DODD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WASN'T GOING TO
SPEAK ON THIS TODAY, BUT, YOU
KNOW, AFTER SOME OF THE
COMMENTS, I MUST SAY I'M PRETTY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE COMMENTS
FROM MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
JOSE. YOU KNOW, ON THIS ISSUE
MALIGNING THE INTEGRITY OF WHAT,
FRANKLY, IS PROBABLY WHAT IS
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED, ONE OF
THE BEST MPOS IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND FRANKLY,
ONE OF THE BEST EXECUTIVES THAT
I'VE EVER WORKED WITH IN 25
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE, THE
FORMER EXECUTIVE THAT HE TOOK ON
THIS IS REALLY NOT ABOUT THE MTC
AND THE MTC LEADERSHIP. WHAT
WE'VE GOT BEFORE US TODAY IS, IS
A BILL THAT HAS BEEN COOKED
PRETTY MUCH, AND WE KNOW HOW
TOUGH THIS IS WHEN YOU'VE GOT
REGIONAL CONCERNS BY THIS
LEGISLATURE WITH SOME INPUT FROM
DULY ELECTED MEMBERS OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THIS ISN'T MTC STAFF
BEHIND THE CURTAINS, HOLDING UP
THE PUPPETS AND MAKING THESE
DECISIONS. THIS IS MEMBERS OF
THEIR COMMISSION. SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO JUST BRING ACROSS IS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALLOW
THIS THING TO GO OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND PERHAPS WHAT WE CAN
DO IS GET A BILL THAT'S LESS
PRESCRIPTIVE THAT WILL ALLOW THE
LOCALS, THE NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES, TO SIT DOWN AT A TABLE
AND TO WORK TO WORK THIS OUT.
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. IF WE
REMEMBER LAST YEAR, WE WERE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE BAY AREA
DIDN'T GET A LARGE ENOUGH SHARE
OF THE TRANSIT SHORTFALL DOLLARS
, AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE. WE
RUN THE VERY RISK OF THESE GREAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
BAY AREA, BAY AREA OF FALLING
SHORT AND PERHAPS MASSIVELY
CUTTING SERVICES, WHICH WOULD BE
A REAL PROBLEM FOR CONGESTION IN
THE BAY AREA. SO I'M HOPING THAT
WE CAN DO THAT MOVING FORWARD
AND GET A YES VOTE ON 1031 AND
HELP THE BAY AREA NOT GO DOWN ON
THE FISCAL CLIFF. REGIONALISM IS
A TOUGH THING, AND I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THE BAY AREA CAN
GET THERE. WE'VE DONE IT IN THE
PAST. AS A PAST CHAIR OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, WE'VE HAD SOME TOUGH
TIMES AND SOME TOUGH
NEGOTIATIONS, EVEN ME, WHEN I
WAS CHAIR OF MTC WITH THE,
FUTURE CHAIR FROM FROM SAN JOSE,
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT A LOT
OF TOUGH, TOUGH ISSUES. AND I
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THIS WILL
WORK IN THE END. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO. WE HAVE TWO ADDITIONAL
MICROPHONES UP. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO SENATOR CABALLERO AND
SENATOR DURAZZO. SENATOR
CABALLERO, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I HAD NO INTENTION OF
SPEAKING. LET ME JUST SAY FROM
THE GET GO THAT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BUT LET ME
TELL YOU HOW FRUSTRATED I AM,
BECAUSE IF I HAD A PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN MY
DISTRICT THAT WORKED, THAT WOULD
BE THE BIGGEST BLESSING IN THE
WORLD. YOU KNOW, WE TALK ABOUT
REDUCING THE TRAFFIC IN THE BAY
AREA. WELL, HELL, I'D LIKE TO
REDUCE IT GOING OVER PACHECO
PASS AND ALTAMONT PASS. I'M
GOING TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON IS THAT YOUR FOLKS ARE
ALL MOVING INTO OUR COMMUNITY.
AND IN MANY WAYS, IT'S BEEN
GREAT. IT IS RAISED THE LEVEL OF
INCOME. IT'S BEEN GOOD FOR OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES, BUT IT'S BEEN
HELL ON OUR ROADWAYS. AND NOT
ONLY THAT, VEHICLE MILES TRAVELS
MEANS THAT EVERY TIME WE BUILD A
HOUSE, IT COSTS A LOT MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO NOW INVENT AN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. BECAUSE I'M
SORRY, BUT IF YOU LIVE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA, HAVING A BIKE PATH,
HAVING A WALKING PATH, AND
THROWING SOME MONEY AT, AT AT A
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM,
THAT DOESN'T WORK IF YOU'VE GOT
TO GO TO WORK OR A MEDICAL
APPOINTMENT OR YOU HAVE AN
EMERGENCY. I MEAN, NONE OF THAT
WORKS. AND SO WE GOT TO GET THIS
DONE. I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN
THE AUTHOR, AND IT'S MY HOPE
THAT, THERE IS A BUDGET DANGLING
SOLUTION WHERE WE START LOOKING
BECAUSE. SO RIGHT NOW, ALL OF
THESE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THÀNH STOP. THEY DON'T COME INTO
OUR REGION AND WE'VE DONE THESE
LITTLE KIND OF STRAWS. THE
ALTAMONT, EXPRESS IS ONE OF
THEM, BUT IT'S NOT HERE YET. AND
THE ABILITY TO HOOK I TAKE THE
TRAIN WHENEVER I CAN, I WON'T I
WON'T DRIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
ANYMORE. IT JUST TOO CRAZY. AND
FRANKLY, THE TRAIN AND THE AMBAR
DOES IT DOES ITS JOB. BUT BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED COLLABORATION.
WE NEED THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO THINK A LITTLE BIT
MORE BROADLY. AND THEY GOT TO
FIGURE OUT, OKAY, HOW DO WE STOP
NOW THAT WE STOP IN MILPITAS FOR
BART? HOW DO WE GET IT DOWN TO
GILROY? AND THEN HOW DO WE GET
IT DOWN TO HOLLISTER AND
SALINAS? AND THEN HOW DO WE GET
SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP GET
PEOPLE OFF OUR OVERCROWDED
HIGHWAYS THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
FIX? BECAUSE IT IS GROWTH
INDUCING? I GOT NEWS FOR YOU,
FOLKS. WE'VE GOT SO MUCH TO FIX.
AND IF WE COULD GET OUT OF OUR
CARS, FORGET ELECTRIC CARS, JUST
GET OUT OF OUR DARN CARS. THAT
COULD MAKE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE ON THE ROADWAYS. AND
SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK BROADER ON SOME OF
THESE. AND I KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING ON A BILL, JUST GETTING
IT PASSED IS IMPORTANT. BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO CONNECT PARTS OF
OUR STATE THAT ARE HOUSING
PEOPLE AND THAT GET THE BRUNT OF
, OF THAT DEVELOPMENT THAT
BECOMES UNMITIGATED BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT BUILDING ROADS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR BARRASSO,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I, I IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT I WAS NOT GOING TO HAVE A
PROBLEM IN SUPPORTING THIS, BUT
WHEN ISSUES OF EQUITY COME TO
THE TABLE, THAT GRABS MY
ATTENTION. AND SEVERAL COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE HERE TODAY, OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE AREA OF THE GENERAL AREA
HAVE RAISED SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES. NOW, IF A, IF
AN AREA LIKE LOS ANGELES WITH 10
MILLION PEOPLE AND A MASSIVE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM CAN
WORK FAIRLY WELL, THERE'S A LOT
OF ISSUES BUT CAN WORK FAIRLY
WELL. WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT TO
DO THE SAME THING IN THE BAY
AREA. I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
FOCUS THAT SHOULD GUIDE US ALL
IS THE FACT THAT THE WORST AND
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION IN OUR AIR IS FROM
EMISSIONS. AND SO WE DON'T WANT
TO ENCOURAGE MORE CARS. WE NEED
TO BE AHEAD OF THE OF THE, THE,
THE ISSUE HERE, WHICH IS OUR
CLIMATE ISSUE, IT'S A CLIMATE
ISSUE AND IT'S A MOVE PEOPLE.
IT'S A MOVE LOGISTICS. IT'S
THAT'S WHAT'S CONFRONTING US.
BUT I WILL I WILL SUPPORT TODAY
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THIS CAME TO
LIGHT, THIS MORNING, BUT I AM A
BIG BELIEVER IN THE EQUITY THAT
NEEDS TO BE MORE. I THINK, MORE
STRONGLY DEMONSTRATED, BECAUSE
IF WE HAVE THESE KINDS OF
DIFFERENCES NOW, SOMETHING'S
MISSING. AND SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT CONVERSATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO A MUCH BETTER
PACKAGE THAT EVERYBODY COULD
SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES BACK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DALLY. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO RISE JUST TO I DON'T
KNOW WHERE I'M GOING TO DO ON
THE BILL AT THIS POINT, BUT I
WANT TO MAKE A POINT TO MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM MERCED AND MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM STOCKTON. WE SPEND
100 BILLION. WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND $100 BILLION ON A TRAIN TO
NOWHERE IN THE VALLEY. AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO
RAISE MORE MONEY FOR THE NINE
BAY AREA COUNTIES. WHY DON'T WE
TAKE THE MONEY THAT'S
MISDIRECTED OVER THERE, THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND SPEND
IT IN AREAS WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY REDUCE THE EMISSIONS?
ULTIMATE PASS TO MERCED, TO THE
AREAS WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY
WE'RE BUILDING A TRAIN IN THE
VALLEY THAT'S GOING NOWHERE WHEN
WE SHOULD BE USING THOSE FUNDS
IN THE BAY AREA AND THOSE THOSE
CITIES OUTSIDE OF THE BAY AREA
TO GET THE PEOPLE TO MOVE IN
THERE. THAT'S WHERE WE COULD
REALLY SAVE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ACTUALLY COMPLETE SOMETHING FOR
A LOT BETTER MONEY. JUST TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION. WE HAVE
THE POWER TO DO THAT IN THIS
BODY, AND WE SHOULD THANK YOU,
SENATOR. MEMBERS GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR RUBIO. GOOD MORNING, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE. YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN A STRONG PROPONENT OF
REGIONAL COLLABORATION FOR
YEARS. YOU KNOW, AND I PRIDE
MYSELF ON SO MANY THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE. YOU KNOW, IN THE
SEYARTO VALLEY TO BRING ALL CITY
TOGETHER, ALL CITIES TOGETHER.
AND I ALSO HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW,
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS HERE. I'VE
BEEN VERY RESPECTFUL WHEN IT'S
DISTRICT SPECIFIC PROJECTS, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE ONLY THOSE THAT
ARE IN THAT REGION AND THOSE
CITIES UNDERSTAND THE PROJECTS
BETTER THAN WE DO, AND BUT I DO
HEAR MY COLLEAGUES FROM STOCKTON
AND MERCED AND THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES WHEN THEY'RE BIGGER
REGIONS, THE LITTLE CITIES
SOMETIMES ARE LEFT OUT. AND THIS
I CAN'T HELP BUT THIS REMINDS ME
OF AN ISSUE I HAD A FEW YEARS
BACK WHERE WE DEBATED A BILL
THAT WAS SOMEWHAT DISTRICT
SPECIFIC FOR LIKE FIVE HOURS.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE IT WAS
THE SAME SORT OF CONCEPT. IT WAS
A BIG CITIES LEAVING LITTLE
CITIES OUT AND, AND WE WERE
DEBATING IT FOR FIVE HOURS
BECAUSE I WAS ASKED TO LET IT
OUT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO FIX IT ALONG
THE WAY. AND IT WASN'T FIXED. IT
WAS VOTED ON. AND HERE YOU KNOW,
SO IT'S HARDER SOMETIMES FOR ME
TO GIVE THOSE COURTESIES NOW
BECAUSE I KNOW IT HAPPENED. AND
YOU ALL REMEMBER WHAT THAT ISSUE
WAS, AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS
EQUITABLE. AND THESE SMALL
CITIES ARE ALWAYS FIGHTING
BIGGER CITIES. NOW, I WON'T
DISPUTE THE FACT THAT BIG CITIES
NEED A LOT OF RESOURCES AND THEY
HAVE A LOT MORE TO CONTEND WITH
IN TERMS OF TRAFFIC AND
CROWDING. BUT BUT I DO WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR, AND I
THINK I HEARD THE AUTHOR SAY
THAT THIS IS NOT DONE. I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE SENTIMENTS
WHICH WERE VERY STRONG, FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE. YOU
KNOW, I HAVE TO HEAR HIM IN THE
SENSE THAT I WAS IN THAT
SITUATION A FEW YEARS BACK AND
THERE WAS NOTHING I CAN DO. IT
WAS, YOU KNOW, THE LITTLE GUY
FIGHTING THE BIG GUY. AND I KNOW
THAT SAN JOSE IS A BIG CITY, BUT
BUT YOU'RE TRYING TO CONTEND
WITH HOW DO WE FIX SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE EQUITABLE? SO
I WILL SUPPORT THIS. BUT WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
EVERYONE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SIT DOWN. AND IT REALLY PAINS ME
TO LET IT OUT WHEN I'M NOT FULLY
COMFORTABLE, BECAUSE IT WOULD
HAPPEN TO ME. BUT I HOPE THAT,
IN HIS CLOSING, I GET ASSURANCES
FROM THE AUTHOR THAT HE WILL SIT
DOWN WITH THESE FOLKS THAT HAVE
CONCERNS TO CONTINUE TO TRY AND
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S A PATH TO
BE MORE INCLUSIVE. AND WITH
THAT, I'LL JUST SIT DOWN AND ASK
THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER THAT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, AT THIS
POINT, TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK
TOGETHER AS A BODY, I THINK WE
NEED TO DO A GO. GIANTS OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR WIENER FOR HIS CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. BOY
ISN'T REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING POLITICS FUN, IT IS. IT
IS FUN, BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
UNBELIEVABLY IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK ALL THE DIFFERENT VIEWS
WE'VE HEARD TODAY, WHICH I
RESPECT, ALTHOUGH THERE WERE
SOME INACCURATE STATEMENTS MADE,
AND I WILL NEED TO CORRECT THE
RECORD. I DON'T EVER MIND PEOPLE
DISAGREEING WITH ME ON ANYTHING
OR FIGHTING WITH ME ON ANYTHING.
I DO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
INACCURATE STATEMENTS AND I'LL
GET TO THAT. BUT I WANT TO BE
VERY, VERY CLEAR WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. THIS IS ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF THE BAY AREA, THE
INTERCONNECTED NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES THAT ARE
INTERCONNECTED, INCLUDING BART.
EVERYONE LOVES BEATING UP ON
BART, WHICH RUNS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH ALAMEDA COUNTY AND SAN
FRANCISCO, SIX STOPS IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND IS GOING TO GO
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO SAN JOSE
BECAUSE WE AS A REGION HAVE
PRIORITIZED FUNDING FOR BART TO
SAN JOSE, WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE PROJECT. BUT WE HAVE
DONE THAT BECAUSE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, LIKE SAN FRANCISCO AND
LIKE OAKLAND AND LIKE SANTA ROSA
IS PART OF OUR INTEGRATED
REGION. AND WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO GET AROUND AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO CHOICE. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
TRANSIT BECAUSE WE HAVE MASSIVE
SERVICE CUTS, THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO GET TO WORK OR GET TO
SCHOOL OR GET TO THE DOCTOR. AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A CHOICE, WHO
MIGHT BE WILLING TO DRIVE LESS
IF THEY'RE CONFIDENT THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GET WHERE
THEY'RE GOING. THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT OUR
SYSTEMS CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE PEOPLE AND GET BETTER AND
BETTER AND BETTER. I DO WANT TO
JUST POINT OUT A FEW INACCURATE
STATEMENTS THAT WERE THAT WERE
MADE JUST SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
FIRST OF ALL, 40, 40% OF THESE
FUNDS, ALMOST HALF OF WILL BE
DIRECTLY ALLOCATED THROUGH THE
MTC. BUT THE MTC HAS NO
DISCRETION IN TWO COUNTIES, JUST
A CHECK CUT TO THE COUNTIES,
WHAT WE CALL IT SUBVENTION. 40%
OF THESE FUNDS WILL HAVE TO BE
SENT TO THE COUNTIES WITH NO
DISCRETION BY THE MTC
WHATSOEVER. THIS DOES HAVE A
RETURN TO SOURCE. IT STARTS AT
70% AND IT GOES UP TO 90% AFTER
FIVE YEARS. AND YES, THAT DIRECT
TO SOURCE ALSO INCLUDES FOR
EXAMPLE, IF A COUNTY BENEFITS
FROM A MULTI COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT SYSTEM
LIKE BART. SO SAN FRANCISCO
BENEFITS FROM BART, SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WILL BE BENEFITING FROM
IT, OR CALTRAIN, WHICH RUNS
THROUGH SANTA CLARA COUNTY, SAN
MATEO COUNTY, SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY. BUT THERE IS A STRONG
RETURN TO SOURCE. IT MAY NOT BE
EXACTLY THE KIND OF RETURN TO
SOURCE THAT SOME PEOPLE WANT,
AND THAT WILL BE A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION. THÀNH, I ALSO I DO
WANT TO JUST SAY TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR, COLLEAGUES, I WANT TO
JUST EXPRESS THIS VALLEY LINK IS
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING UNDER THIS
MEASURE. IT IS EVEN THOUGH SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY WILL NOT BE
PAYING TAXES UNDER THIS. IT'S
THE NINE BAY AREA COUNTIES. EVEN
THOUGH SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY WILL
NOT BE PAYING TAXES, VALLEY LINK
IS ELIGIBLE BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR VALLEY LINK TO
SUCCEED. AND I WANT TO STRESS
THAT IF BART HAS TO MAKE SERVICE
CUTS, THAT IS TERRIBLE FOR
VALLEY LINK BECAUSE VALLEY LINK
DEPENDS ON CONNECTING THE BART.
AND SO IT'S IN EVERYONE'S
INTEREST TO SHORE UP THESE
SYSTEMS. AND I ALSO JUST WANT TO
SAY THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO, I THAT I KNOW IT'S
REALLY EASY TO TAKE POT SHOTS AT
SAN FRANCISCO. THIS IS ABOUT ALL
OF THE COUNTIES. THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO GO REGIONALLY
EVERYWHERE. AND TAKING A POT
SHOT AT SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE IT
SELLS WELL. IT'S NOT ACCURATE
AND IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE. AND I
TAKE MAJOR ISSUE WITH THAT. SO
COLLEAGUES, THIS IS ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
IN THE BAY AREA. I WANT US TO BE
CONNECTED TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY,
AND THERE ARE PROJECTS UNDERWAY
TO DO THAT. AND I SUPPORT THOSE,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND OF COURSE, WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK INTENSIVELY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. I JUST SPOKE TO
THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO, AND WE'LL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT WORK. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 21 ALAN
ALVARADO. GIL NØ. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CORTEZ. NØ. DALY DODD I DURAZZO
I EGGMAN. GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE. I
MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN I WYNN.
NO. NILO. NO. OKUBO NO. PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
SAWYER ITO. NO. SKINNER. I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN ARCHULETA. BRADFORD I
DALLEY. NO EGGMAN. HURTADO I MEN
RUBIO I WILK. NO AYES 26. NOES
TEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
CABALLERO. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, IT GIVES ME GREAT
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE UC MERCED,
CAPE LEGISLATURE FELLOWS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN A WEEK LONG
LEGISLATIVE TRADING TRAINING
PROGRAM. THEY WERE ACCOMPANIED
TODAY BY THEIR PROFESSORS,
DOCTOR NATE MONROE AND FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY. THEY
HAD TO LEAVE, SO I'M
DISAPPOINTED THEY DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO BE RECOGNIZED PRIOR TO
THIS. BUT IF YOU COULD GIVE THEM
A BIG WELCOME, THEY'LL SEE IT ON
TV AND THEY'RE GOING. WELCOME.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM 36.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 96 8999 14 926 945
965 972 978 980 1000 1014 1033,
1069, 1090, 1098, 1100 1101,
1112, 1163, 1176, 1214, 12, 18,
1233, 1281, 1288, 1322, 1339, 14
1514, 25, 1455, 1459, 1469,
1463, 1477. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR
AMEN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE. NHIÀU OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA. GROVE AYE.
LIMON. AYE. NILO AYE. AGE 38
NOES. ZERO. SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR IS CONFIRMED. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE. SENATOR,
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO MOVE FILE
ITEM 19, SB 1494 TO THE ACTIVE
FILE. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME, WE'LL HEAR
CLOSING REMARKS FROM MINORITY
LEADER AND OUR PRESIDENT PRO
TEM, SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
CONGRATULATIONS ON A GREAT WEEK.
I THINK WE'VE DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB, THIS WEEK ON THE BILLS THAT
WERE BIPARTISAN. I APPRECIATE
THE GREAT COOPERATION FROM THE
ENTIRE BODY ON THE BILLS THAT
WEREN'T BIPARTISAN. I APPRECIATE
THE PROFESSIONAL DEBATE. AND, AS
EACH ONE OF US REPRESENT THE 1
MILLION PEOPLE THAT EACH OF US
REPRESENT, I THINK WE BRING THAT
PASSION. WE BRING THAT
INTELLIGENCE, WE BRING THAT
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT FOR OUR FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS TO THIS FLOOR.
WE DEBATE HONESTLY WITH
INTEGRITY, AND I APPRECIATE
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH EACH AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU,
REGARDING THE WEEK SPECIFICALLY,
I WANT TO THANK PRO TEM MCGUIRE
AND MAJORITY LEADER GONZALEZ FOR
THEIR GREAT LEADERSHIP THIS
WEEK. THE FLOOR TEAM FROM THE
DEMOCRAT CAUCUS THAT DID A GREAT
JOB KEEPING THE TRAINS RUNNING
ON TIME. WAIT, THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN A BAD PUN TODAY, BUT,
KEEPING THE BILL PRESENTATIONS
GOING AND MEMBERS ON POINT,
WE'VE HAD AN EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE HOUSE OF ORIGIN
DEADLINE BECAUSE OF THE PLANNING
AND EXECUTION OF THAT TEAM. I
WANT TO THANK THE ENTIRE STAFF,
FLOOR STAFF, BERNIE, ERIKA, THE
ENTIRE TEAM FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE THIS WEEK, TO ALSO
HELP KEEP THINGS MOVING. THIS
PLACE WOULDN'T RUN WITHOUT THE
MANY STAFFERS THAT SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS MAKING THE
SENATE RUN LIKE A WELL-OILED
MACHINE, WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
EMOTIONAL DEBATE THIS WEEK, AND.
AND I THINK THAT GOES TO SHOW
HOW MUCH WE CARE ABOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW MUCH WE
CARE ABOUT OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND
I HOPE THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
TO THE OTHER HOUSE WITH OUR
BILLS AND THEIR BILLS COME OVER
HERE, THAT THE SENATORS WILL
KEEP THAT SAME, CANDOR AND
PROFESSIONALISM AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO A
GREAT END OF SESSION WHEN WE ARE
WRAPPING UP IN AUGUST. NOW,
LET'S GO HOME, ENJOY OUR
FAMILIES FOR THE WEEKEND, AND
PLEASE REMEMBER ALL OF THOSE
THAT HAVE SERVED US IN OUR
MILITARY AND THOSE THAT HAVE
GAVE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE FOR
KEEPING OUR COUNTRY FREE AND
THAT FLAG FLYING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
MR. PETE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT
AND LEADER JONES, WE NEED THAT
PIE FOR BREAKFAST MORE THAN EVER
THIS MORNING. SO I APPRECIATE
ALL THE CARBS THIS WEEK.
MEMBERS. AS YOU KNOW, ALONG WITH
THE BUDGET AND AT THE END OF
SESSION, THE HOUSE OF ORIGIN
DEADLINE IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PILLARS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE YEAR. AND THIS
ESTEEMED BODY, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE. WE MET THE
CHALLENGE HEAD ON WITH GRACE.
SOME GRIT, AND A TOUCH OF SPICY
DEBATE. MOVING OVER 344 BILLS TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIS WEEK, THE
SENATE. WE ARE COMMITTED,
COMMITTED AS A BODY TO TACKLE
THE STATE'S TOUGHEST CHALLENGES
AND LIFT UP THE COMMUNITIES AND
THE PEOPLE. WE ARE SO HONORED TO
BE ABLE TO REPRESENT AND IN MANY
CASES, AS THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
SAID, WE ARE DOING THIS IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER, PUTTING
POLITICS ASIDE AND PUTTING THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST. WE OWE YOU
EACH OF THE SENATORS IN THESE
CHAMBERS, A HEARTFELT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS WORK THIS
WEEK. YOU'VE ALL PUT IN LONG
HOURS WITH A LOT OF PRESSURE,
AND WE'RE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE MANY
PEOPLE WHO KEEP, AS THE LEADER
SAID, THE TRAINS RUNNING ON TIME
AND THE OPERATION SMOOTH, OF
COURSE, TO THE ONE, THE ONLY
BERNIE MCNULTY AND THE ENTIRE
DESK TEAM. WE LOVE YOU, BERNIE.
YOU ARE THE BEST. MY GOODNESS.
SECRETARY ERICA CONTRERAS DOES
YEOMAN'S WORK EACH AND EVERY
DAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SECRETARY CONTRERAS. WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR CHIEF
SERGEANT KATRINA RODRIGUEZ AND
THE SENATE SERGEANTS. WE WANT TO
SAY ABSOLUTELY TO THE REPUBLICAN
AND THE DEMOCRATIC POLICY TEAMS.
CAN WE PLEASE GIVE THEM A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE? TO REPUBLICAN
LEADER BRIAN JONES. THANK YOU.
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP. I
KNOW THAT WE MAY NOT ALWAYS
AGREE, BUT WHAT WE FOCUS IS
FOCUS IN ON PUTTING THE PEOPLE
FIRST. AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP. MISTER LEADER, I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
OUR MAJORITY LEADER, SENATOR
GONZALES. OUR ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADERS, ASHBY AND WAHAB AND THE
ENTIRE FLOOR TEAM. CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR MOVING US
FORWARD AND KEEPING US, ON TIME?
AND CANDIDLY, ABOVE SCHEDULE
EACH AND EVERY WEEK. THANK YOU
TO SENATE-TV AND THE IT FOLKS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE ENTIRE STAFF TEAM
AND THE PRO TEM SHOP AND OUR
FLOOR UNIT LED BY NICOLE BAROUCH
NICOLE. WE COULDN'T DO WHAT WE
DO WITHOUT YOU EACH AND EVERY
DAY. AND SPORTING THE PENGUIN.
THEME TODAY AS WELL. I'M GOING
TO END IT RIGHT HERE SO THAT
EVERYBODY CAN CATCH A FLIGHT. I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE MANY
TIMES OUR JOBS ARE ABOUT WHAT'S
NEXT AND WHAT'S NEXT IS A TON OF
WORK. WE ARE IMMEDIATELY GOING
TO PIVOT TO THE BUDGET AND SOME
TOUGH DECISIONS AHEAD. AFTER
THAT, WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
OUR BILLS IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND
WE WELCOME HUNDREDS OF ASSEMBLY
BILLS INTO THE SENATE. SO
THERE'S A LOT MORE IN FRONT OF
US. BUT I WANTED TO STOP AND
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO WHAT'S NEXT
. THANK YOU. SAFE TRAVELS. WE
HOPE YOU GET TO SPEND TIME WITH
FRIENDS AND FAMILY THIS WEEKEND,
AND TO BE ABLE TO HONOR THOSE
WHO PAID THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
SO LET ALL OF US CAN LIVE IN A
THRIVING DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM
UNTIL TUESDAY, MAY 28TH. WE HOPE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL AND SAFE
WEEKEND. THAT'S WHEN THE NEXT
FOUR SESSION WILL BE. MR.
PRESIDENT, I'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. PRO TEM. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30
P.M, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE ON TUESDAY,
MAY 28TH, 2024 AT 2 P.M.